in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for August 22, on which we commemorate,
the Holy Martyr Agathonicos.
On the 22nd of the month, we celebrate the memory of the Holy Martyr Agathonicos
and his companions, Zoticos, Zeno, Thelprepios, Akindinos, and Severian.
At the time of Maximian's persecution, Count Eftolmius was charged by the Emperor
to make the Christians submit.
He traveled from Nicomedia to Pontus, shedding blood wherever he went.
Contrary to his expectations, however, people of good will, among them soldiers and even brigands,
admiring the courage of the true disciples of Christ, declared themselves to be Christians.
There were many who left the towns and retired to the country to live according to the evangelical precepts in small groups.
Eftolmius had many slain by the sword and threatened to load those of noble birth with chains and bring them before the Emperor.
From Neosessaria, he arrived in the small town of Carpus in Bethinia, where Zoticos,
the most important Christian of the town, was brought before him.
When the Count demanded to know why he taught his fellow citizens to disdain the sacrifices offered to the gods of the Empire,
he replied that, in this, he was obeying the Word of God, found in the Holy Scripture.
Commanded to sacrifice under pain of death, he replied, Christ desires me as a sacrifice,
that his name may be glorified to the ends of the earth.
After a summary judgment, he was executed along with some of his disciples,
the faithful secretly coming afterwards to see their burial.
Returning to Nicomedia, Eftolmius was welcomed by the ovations of the pagans and psychofants.
They were obliged, however, to report to him that the Emperor, having departed for Thrace,
the leading man of the city had been converted to the doctrine of Christ by Agathonicos, the sage,
son of the prefect Asglipiados, a descendant of one of the most illustrious Roman families,
and that they were both living in the village of Kubaina.
The count was furious and sent soldiers to the village to arrest them.
When the detachment arrived at their house, St. Agathonicos gave glory to Christ and promised that,
trusting in the power of Christ's name, he would faithfully give his testimony to the end.
When the soldiers saw his courage, they too were converted,
nevertheless constrained to carry out their mission. They took the saint to Nicomedia.
Eftolmius had Agathonicos appear before him in a place named Lampsos and asked him whether he had persuaded
the leader of the local senate to become a Christian.
The saint replied that it behoved him to obey God rather than men,
and he recalled the glorious testimony given by the martyrs of former times,
St. Bavilas and St. Romanos, who had been martyred while he was still a child by the prefect Asglipiados,
his own father, and Bishop Anthimos of Nicomedia.
His Apologia reduced the magistrate and his assistants to stupified silence.
When well-informed people told Eftolmius that Agathonicos' family had come from Rome to live in Nicomedia in obedience to a divine prediction,
the saint added that he who renounces lands, riches, and renown for the sake of the gospel,
will receive a hundredfold in this life and will inherit eternal life.
The count had him whipped and thrown into prison, intending to have him taken before the emperor with the other nobles who had been arrested,
and ordered that the Christians of more humble origins be slain by the sword.
A great number were taken to the highest point in the city where they prayed unceasingly while waiting to render their supreme testimony of faith.
Anxious about the growing success of Agathonicos' preaching, the influential people of the city pressed the magistrate to send him and his companions without delay to the emperor.
The following day, Eftolmius set out with his prisoners, followed at a distance by the faithful of Nicomedia, who were grieving at the loss of their new apostle.
Saint Agathonicos turned towards them and said,
You have Jesus and the saints with you, who pray for you with a pure heart.
Be converted in fear and truth and live thus for the rest of your days.
The tyrant wore out his prisoners by hunger, the long journey and torture.
When they stopped in the village of Potami, he had Zeno, and Thelprepios and Akindinos, two of his companions, officers who had been converted by Agathonicos, brought before him.
When torture proved useless, he had them torn to pieces on a rack.
When the group arrived in Calcedon, pagan priests took an old man named Severian before Eftolmius.
Severian had encouraged Saint Efemia in her martyrdom.
They accused him of having transformed the pritorium of Darius into a catechetical school and thereby of drawing a growing number of citizens to his cause.
The count questioned him and when he found that he was eager to condemn the pagans and predict the divine punishment that would fall on them, he had him executed at a place a short distance from the city.
The other saints were taken to Byzantium, where they appeared before the tribunal.
Agathonicos was the first to be interrogated and ordered to submit to the emperor's orders.
He replied that the word of God in the psalm tells us not to follow the councils of the wicked and not to walk in the way of sinners, but to perfect ourselves in our faith in Christ.
The judge asked furiously, if he whom you confess is truly God and king, how is it that he was put to death by the Jews?
Why has he not delivered from death those who, following his example, are opposed to our gods?
Be persuaded and renounce this folly.
The saint replied by confessing his faith in the power of the Savior who suffered for us.
The sentence was finally pronounced and he was taken outside the city to be flayed alive on its ramparts.
While his flesh and blood were mingling with the earth, Agathonicos turned towards his companions, assuring them that the sufferings of the present moment are not to be compared with the glory which is reserved for the servants of Christ in the kingdom.
These words, supported by the testimony of his blood, converted several of the judges and soldiers to the faith.
After this torture, Eftolmios took a swift horse and went off hastily to find Maximian in Selibria in Thrace.
On the banks of the sea of Marmara, and after having given an account of his actions he brought before him the Christians of noble birth,
whom he had recently tortured.
When Agathonicos' turn came to state his identity, Maximian recognized that he belonged to his own family and asked him why he had been arrested.
The saint replied that it was for the sake of Christ who had ordered his disciples to offer themselves as a spectacle before the whole world
and before the angels in order to witness to the gospel.
He added that it was better to undergo torture in this life rather than be delivered to the eternal fire into which the impious and tyrants like himself would be cast.
Maximian listened attentively to his words, but remaining obterate he ordered that he be killed with his companions.
He then decreed that the persecution which had failed to stop the spread of the good news should cease.
Saint Agathonicos went to the scaffold with joy and after a last prayer was beheaded along with the senator and many other Christians whom he had converted and whose names are written in the book of life.
The Christians of Celibria, afterwards, venerated Saint Agathonicos as the protector and patron of their city.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.